Faith in Islam and Muslim one. Faith in
Islam and Muslim one. Nick, I'll let you
do the honors, man. Which one we
bringing up?
>> Am I in here though? Am I in here?
>> Sounds like someone's already here.
>> Oh, wait. What? What is happening? Who's
that? You're on for like
>> You on TikTok?
>> You sitting here for like 2 hours? No,
it wasn't.
>> Not 2 hours, but like for 30 minutes. It
was when Mike came up, I was already on
here.
>> Wait, you're on TikTok?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> I remember you joined um on accident.
Um,
>> click
>> I got to click Tik Tok.
>> I got a ghost up here,
>> bro. What's happening? Cuz I I can't see
my whole
>> I'm Let me go to your Tik Tok. Hold on.
>> He's there.
>> Oh, you see him there? Okay.
>> But I can't on like on Tik Tok Studios.
Something glitched to where I can only
see us and my type my topic.
>> That's weird.
>> It glitched, man.
>> That's crazy. I've been I thought you
was just skipping me on purpose.
>> Yeah, I couldn't see you. No, I I didn't
see I couldn't see you. I didn't know
that you Sorry about that, man.
>> But but go ahead. You say you disagree?
>> Yeah, of course, man.
>> Okay. What's What's your religion?
>> I I don't have one. I just believe in a
one God.
>> You don't have a religion, but you
believe in one God.
>> I know anything about that one God.
>> What do you mean from the word? From the
scriptures.
>> Scriptures.
>> What? So, I need to label myself a
religion to believe in a God.
>> At least tell at least tell us what
scriptures you follow. What scriptures?
>> We already know what's going to be.
the Tanakh then the New Testament.
>> Okay. So you follow the Bible.
>> I was wrong. I thought he was going to
say Quran. I'll be honest. I'll be
honest.
>> Okay. So um so okay. So you follow the
Bible and you say that Jesus is not God.
Why do you say that?
>> Cuz the Bible clearly says Yahweh is
God.
>> And it clearly says Jesus is Yahweh.
>> All right. Uh show me.
>> Go to uh I'mma pull up for you. My my
tech guys is trying to figure things out
real quick.
>> That guy's crazy.
>> My mouse is working just fine, man. Look
at that. Just a little glitch. That's I
don't know what's happening over here,
guys. We having some technical
difficulties. But even like Okay, so um
in first in in 1 Corinthians chapter 10.
1 Corinthians chapter 10. You familiar
with uh this these passages over here?
>> I'll look it up. Yeah. 1 Corinthians.
>> Oh, you got your Bible on you? I hear
you flipping pages.
>> Yes, sir.
>> For sure.
>> That's what I'm talking about. 1
Corinthians chapter 10.
>> I don't use my physical Bible enough. I
rarely use it anymore.
>> That's terrible.
>> Is it though?
>> Yes. Same thing. Keep my laptop.
>> How do you retain the verses and stuff?
>> Because I write it my notes on my Google
Docs. Oh,
>> okay. Wait, you write that or you type
that?
>> Typed it. Same thing.
>> Okay. What does 1 Samuel 3:15 say?
Exactly.
>> I'm so cooked. Dang.
>> Exactly.
>> So, you start start picking up that
physical Bible, you would have been able
to recite. No,
>> you ain't lying. Cooked, man. I got
better. I should be able to recite the
whole Bible, man.
>> The whole Bible, man, from memory. print
it back.
>> Yeah, I'm not going to lie, man. I I
don't know if I could have you on after
that.
>> Yeah, it was uh it was nice knowing you,
bro.
>> It was nice knowing you, too, man. I
appreciate all your help. Um but uh
yeah.
>> Am I a heretic now?
>> Technically. Yeah.
>> Dang.
>> You're going against 2,000 years of
church history.
>> Church fathers ain't li
>> and whoever whatever church father
didn't even know all of it, they
heretics, too. I'm fine.
>> We got Makita in the house who says,
"Excellent conversation with Michael and
shout out to him for his honesty, God
logic, and fearless superb work in
leading individuals to Christ."
Question. Thank you so much, sister.
Appreciate you. God bless you. Question.
Will you ever bring up the LGBT plus
community for guidance or no?
>> Go ahead. Be controversial. Go ahead.
Oh, I I I don't I don't mind
controversy, but uh shoot, not on this
channel. I I I'll bring them up on my
other channel that, you know, if it get
banned.
>> So, yeah, I I you know, on GL Media, we
could start doing some live,
>> you know, dedicated for the Rainbow
community to start coming up and joining
and engaging. Yeah, for sure. For sure.
>> You wouldn't even be able to do that on
Tik Tok, though.
>> No. Yeah, I wouldn't be able to do it on
Tik Tok unless I
>> know
>> make another account and maybe you know
>> I feel like when you use Tik Tok studio
you're less likely to get banned though.
I don't know what it is but
>> Well, they they know me up there so I
might I might be all right. Those lies
and be cool.
>> Call a CEO.
>> Yeah, they know me. But
>> me straight,
>> you know. Wow. Your text guy lowkey is a
beast on these Muslims. My tech guy is a
beast on these Muslims. And it's not
even lowkey, man. Do you want to know
who came up with the question, would you
follow a religion with corrupted
scripture? That was me. That was me. I
don't know why he's laughing. Um cuz we
are each other. So,
man,
>> nice save. Nice.
>> He start busting. Shoot.
>> Yeah, exactly. It happens. You know,
you're forgiven.
>> You know, you still there, brother, on
TikTok.
>> I forgot he was even there. So you said
uh Corinthians 10.
>> Yeah. 1 Corinthians chapter 10. You're
going to read verse 9. What uh what
Bible version you got?
>> New King James.
>> New King James. Okay. All right. Go
ahead.
>> Nor let us tempt Christ as some of them
be also tempted and were destroyed by
serpents.
>> When was Christ tempted and then the
people that tempted him were destroyed
by serpents?
>> What about me?
>> What about you, sweetheart?
>> Oh, so y'all are nice.
>> Babe, that's that's a nobrainer.
>> Wow. Now I'm leaving. Bye.
>> Where you going?
>> Wow. I'm now I'm just getting attacked.
>> That's what you get, man. That's what
you get. Calling me heretic, bro.
>> Wow.
>> She came in. She came in and defended
me. That's what it is.
>> That's wild. Now Nick over here
boasting.
>> Wife, man. What can I say?
>> She can't say that to me. I'm the shake,
brother. Uh so yeah. When when was
Christ tempted and then those same those
people were uh destroyed by serpents?
>> Yeah. I don't recall him being present
at that time,
>> but Paul says he was present at that
time. It says it happened to him. When
were when were they destroyed by
serpents?
>> When Moses um forgot exactly what
account, but I think they were uh it's
in Exodus somewhere.
>> It's in numbers.
>> I don't know what you're talking about.
>> Numbers. Yeah,
>> I believe 21. Let me just double check
here. Make sure we in the right place.
Arad destroyed. Yeah. Yeah. Yep. And 21.
Okay. Wait, let me just make sure we uh
Is it 21?
>> Yeah, it is 21.
>> Okay. So, where in the world? Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Where's it? Uh, okay.
There it is. Yeah.
>> Verse verse five. Verse 5 and six. Mhm.
Verse 5 and 6. Numbers 21 verse 5 and 6.
>> How did we get to numbers?
>> So, it says it says, well, let me put on
the screen, too, so you can see it as
well. All right. But it says, "And the
people spoke against God and against
Moses, why have you brought us up out of
Egypt to die in the wilderness? For
there is no food and no water, and we
loathe the worthless food." Wow. So they
speak up against God, against Yahweh,
and against Moses, right? And so then
what happened? Then Yahweh sent fiery
serpents among the people and they bit
the people so that many people of Israel
died and the people came to Moses and
said, "We have sinned for we have spoken
against Yahweh and against you." Right?
So it was Yahweh who was tempted and
then he destroyed them by serpents.
Right?
>> Yes.
>> But Paul says that it was Christ that
was tempted and they were destroyed by
serpents. So who is he saying Christ is?
Can you look at the uh the Greek script?
See what it says?
>> Sure.
>> See if you had a physical Bible. We
could get there easier.
>> The Drew. Why doesn't it have
>> Look at him. Look at him. He don't know
where to go. Shut up.
>> Boom. Right there, homie. Boom. Boom.
Wait. No.
>> Struggling. Lord have mercy.
>> No. Not three nine. There it is.
>> Boom.
>> Why you sweating, ho? Why you sweating,
>> man? He said, "Why you sweating?" That's
crazy.
>> Made me nervous, God. Oh my god. All
right. See? All right. I'm back. I'm
back. I'm here.
>> So in the Greek here, neither should we
test the Christristone
as some of them tested and and by
serpents were destroyed.
>> Yeah, that kind of changed the whole uh
concept like the whole point in that the
Greek, right? Let us not tempt Christ.
It is. It literally says, "Neither shall
we test the Christ
>> as some of them did." When was Christ
tested? When was Christ tempted and they
were destroyed by serpents?
>> That that's You see the comma there?
>> Yes.
>> That doesn't that doesn't exist in the
Greek.
>> I know, but the author they meant
>> let us not tempt Christ as some of them
did tested him.
>> Tested Tested who?
>> Christ.
>> I mean, I can't really see the whole
screen.
>> Yeah, you can. What are you talking
about? It's right there. I'm looking at
it.
>> Does it Does it say neither should we
test as some of them tested Christ?
>> It says neither. Look, bro. I'm I'mma
read it and hopefully let's let's let's
be honest here cuz let's please don't
please you've been very patient. So, I
would I would hate for you to to now
waste my time with after you've been
patient this long. Let's be honest with
what we're reading. Neither should we
test the Christ the Christ as some of
them tested and were and by serpents
were destroyed. So they tested Christ in
the past and were destroyed by serpents.
>> Do you I mean I'm not trying to be smart
or anything. Do you see how different
that is from the English translation?
>> Tell me what the difference is. So, in
the English translation, right, it
literally says,
>> "We must not put Christ to the test as
some of them did and were destroyed by
serpents." What's different? What's the
difference? I
>> I get your point. So, how do you
distinguish the father and the son if
they're both Yahweh?
>> Well, the father begets the son, sends
the son.
>> No, no, no, no. I know. I know that.
According to Old Testament, the Old
Testament, how do you distinguish the
father from the son if they're both
Yahweh?
>> Same, same way. The the father sends the
son. The son acts upon the father's
behalf. Right? The father sends the son
and tells them to obey him or else he
won't forgive their sins. You know, we
see in the old testament that the son
comes to Moses and Abraham and Hagar and
all these people, right? So, there's a
distinction between him and the father,
Yahweh, the father who sends him. But
both of you
>> well if you're if you're reading the Old
Testament, right, it it kind of implies
that there is one being who's doing the
sending, right?
>> One person one person doing the sending
sending another person who has that same
being, the angel of the Lord. Yes. Can
you give me an example of where God sent
Jesus in the Old Testament or where
Yahweh where where the father sent the
son and it's like you can clearly see
that that's the case
>> that there's a distinction between the
two.
>> Yeah. Like the father is the one doing
the sending and then the son is
>> well let's be let's let's be clear first
before we before we jump to something
else. Can we agree that according to the
scripture, Christ is also Yahweh?
>> We might not we might not we might we
must not put Christ to the test as some
of the old uh the people of the old did.
I mean the English version implies that
yeah they're putting Christ to the test
as they did in the Old Testament. Yeah,
that's what it says in the English
translation.
>> So that means Jesus is Yahweh, right?
>> Are you going to kick me if I say no?
Yeah, because then you'll be being
dishonest. If you say yes, that shows
that you're being honest to the text.
But
>> this is an ambiguous verse, though, cuz
like I said, the Greek verse, the Greek
version.
>> That's just as bad as me as saying no.
Saying that this is ambiguous when you
yourself just said that, yeah, it's it's
putting Christ back then in numbers
that's saying that he was the one that
was tempted by these people. You
yourself also came to that conclusion by
reading this. So if you're when you're
denying what you yourself are reading,
that's that's what's hard for me, bro.
That's that's what makes me kick people
and not have long conversations when
people can't be honest.
>> It's hard for me to accept when the when
the exact same passage, right? He's
talking about Christ being the rock.
>> Exactly. Symbolic.
>> So the rock is wait. It's not symbolic.
>> The rock who was sustaining Israel. Who
is that? According to the Old Testament,
>> it in according to the Old Testament, it
was a literal rock that Moses struck and
water came bringing forth water out of
>> No, but who's the rock? Who's the rock
that traveled with Israel and sustained
them through the wilderness? Cuz that's
what that's what it says earlier in
verse three. Who's the who's the rock?
>> That's what I'm saying. It's it wasn't a
person. It was a rock. A literal rock,
though.
>> Okay. So, let me just show you this.
Let's show Let's see this. So, we got
let's do this verse three,
I'm sorry. What was it? Is it four?
>> But that's kind of why I'm asking like
how do you make a distinction if he was
the rock?
>> For they for they drink from they drank
from the same from the spiritual rock
that followed them and the rock was
Christ. So, the spiritual rock was
sustaining them and followed them
throughout the wilderness. Right. Can
you show me where?
>> Just really quick. Does it Does it say
that? Does it say that the rock
>> That's where That's what Paul says.
>> Okay. And who And who was that rock that
followed them?
>> Supposedly Christ.
>> Supposedly or is is that what it says?
You said you believe you said you
believe the Bible.
>> In the text in the text, it says Christ.
Yeah.
>> So according to the text, Christ was
there in the wilderness sustaining
Israel, right?
>> Yes. According to Corinthians.
>> Awesome. And so who was that rock
according when we look in the Old
Testament? Who was that rock that
followed them in the wilderness? Who was
that?
>> It was Jesus.
>> Yeah. But in the Old Testament, who does
it say that was?
>> It was a rock.
>> Let me show you. What's the only thing
we do, Nick?
>> We just read.
>> That's it, man.
>> When we find the verse,
>> when we find the verse. All right. So,
here it is. This Deuteronomy chapter 32,
the Torah. Give ear, O heavens, and I
will speak. And let the earth hear the
words of my mouth. May my teaching drop
as the rain, my speech distill as the
dew, like gentle rain upon tender grass,
and like showers upon the herb. For I
will proclaim the name of the Lord, the
name of Yahweh. Ascribe greatness to our
God, the rock. His work is perfect, for
all his ways are justice, a God of
faithfulness and without iniquity, just
and upright is he. Who's the rock that
was with Israel throughout the
wilderness that Moses is singing about?
>> Is that what this is?
>> I mean, is this what it's talking about?
The rock that was following them in the
wilderness? Cuz the rock
>> moderators, go ahead and go ahead and uh
do your thing cuz I can't see him in my
mind.
>> Yeah, you should be. Why are you being
disingenuous though?
>> You said now I'm being disingenuous,
man. Get off my stage. Moderators, get
get rid of this dude, man.
>> Bro, is this talking about the rock that
was following?
>> I I'll let you I'll let you think about
that,
>> bro. Don't even let us. What the heck?
>> It won't let you kick him.
>> Either that or I don't have super mod.
>> Can somebody
give me all my mod abilities,
>> bro? You had all your mod abilities.
>> It won't let us.
>> It won't It won't let y'all
stuck.
>> Yeah, it's not letting none of us,
bro.
works out.
>> Exactly.
Go ahead and continue on.
>> I'm not about to close this.
>> Just close it, bro. I'm not
disconnecting. I want to
>> Man, get off Get off my live, bro.
>> Maybe turn off guest request on the left
panel.
>> Get off my live. I can't Look, I've told
you, Nick. My my whole screen is like
cropped to where I can't see.
>> Life's not doing his job then, bro.
>> I can't see comments.
>> Tell Life to do his job.
>> There's a whole glitch here, man. I
can't remove him. Just like you.
>> That's crazy, bro. That's so crazy. This
is This is actually
>> I can't I can't even move. I can't even
move the screen around. What is this,
bro?
>> Show me. Show me how those This is the
rock that was
>> I'll show you in a second.
>> I'll show you in just a second. I'll
show you in just a second.
>> He know,
>> bro. I can't even I can't even. All
right. I'm just I'm just blocking to be
weird.
>> All right, man.
>> That's cool. He said that's cool,
>> bro.
>> Bro, I could never be this weird, bro.
>> See, that's that's your pro. That's the
problem you guys have, right? You guys
want to steer the
>> Bro, get off my stream, man.
>> Want you to get off the stage.
>> Get off my stream. You You a weirdo.
>> Get off my stream.
>> Stay on here, bro. Stay on here, bro.
I'm staying on
>> strange individuals, bro.
>> I can't I can't even do the watch. Watch
your head. I can't do nothing. That's
crazy. This is so good. Hey, you got
control of your whole computer, bro.
>> Dang, bro.
>> Bro, what is that?
>> No, I I ain't hack you or nothing, bro.
I ain't hack you or nothing. I I ain't
do nothing. I don't know what's going
on,
>> bro. Get off my live. That's what going
on. Get off my live.
>> You really don't want to talk to me,
bro? I'm just going to get off. I feel
like
>> Thank you.
>> I just want to say you're this.
>> There's nothing to say anything. Just
get off the stage, bro. Just go on and
get off the stage. Your words are
falling.
>> Oh my gosh. Finally, bro. Dear Lord.
Something up with these
>> You were able to kick him? No, he just
left and then they kicked him out. Oh,
>> okay. You should have been did that.
>> I didn't know. I didn't know that's how
you had to do it.
>> What? How do you do that?
>> I blocked him and then it kicked him.
>> Oh, yeah. That works.
>> Yeah. I can't I can't do anything. I
can't even end my stream if I wanted to.
I can't I can't It cropped. The Tik Tok
studio is cropped in a way where I can't
see comments. I can't like edit.
>> Have to restart his whole PC and just
hope he ain't still live when it
restarted.
>> For real.
>> You at the 3 hour mark. Close Tik Tok.
It might not.
>> I can't.
>> Oh, wait. You can't even
>> I'm trying to exit. I'm Look, close
window. It ain't closing.
>> Wait, what if you click your task
manager here? Okay, look. Logic. Logic.
Uh, go down to your little windows down
here, like where your Windows tab pull
up. Right click. Click task manager.
>> Oh, right click. All right. Task
>> task manager. Click task manager. Find
Tik Tok Studio. And then right click on
it and click end task.
>> Find Tik Tok Studio right there.
>> All right. Boom. I feel it.
>> Now, right click it and click end task.
>> End task.
>> All right. There it is. It's gone.
>> Yeah.
>> Now,
>> look at how you froze.
>> Now, you should be good now.
>> You froze on TikTok looking crazy.
>> It should end. It should end.
>> That's cool how they did, man.
>> That's a funny. I ain't going to lie.
No, it should end though cuz the task is
done.
>> Okay.
>> Now, just now just restart. Now, restart
Tik Tok up now. You should be good.
>> Okay.
>> No, it should be fine.
>> Yeah.
>> Anytime app is glitched like that, you
got to just end the task.
>> I didn't I I didn't know I could do I I
didn't know I could end task. I should
be I should be the one getting paid to
be attacked, man. That's crazy.
>> I'm not going to lie to you, man. You
might be you might be put on the team,
man.